mesdames messieurs bonsoir l'image du
couple cherchait ce coup exécuté a battu
par un peloton militaire c'est cette
image que les roumains attendait depuis
l'annoncé hier de sa condamnation à mort
par un tribunal militaire mais en ce
moment dans un véritable psychodrame si
l'on puis dire la télévision roumains en
direct nous allons voir des images tout
de suite le procès ce fameux procès de
chercher secours que l'on attendait
depuis quelques jours je vous propose de
le voir tout de suite en direction
d'antenne traduit immédiatement par
notre traducteur andry fournit donc
ceausescu et sa femme viennent d'être
accusés ils ont refusé de répondre sauf
devant la grande assemblée nationale ne
reconnaissent pas le nouveau pouvoir
il ya un avocat qui est en train de dire
que que tout homme a droit à la justice
et que c'est au président de décider au
président du pays qui qui en ce moment
donc n'existe pas les gens refusaient de
répondre à toutes les questions et ils
seront opposés évidemment en défenseur
de la classe ouvrière mais ne
reconnaissant que les élus du peuple
donc l'assemblée nationale qui vient
d'être dissoute contraints d'assister
sur le fait que tout semble être
accompli respecté et il
les deux inculpés commettre une erreur
d'une reconnaissance
je suis venu défendre mais ils
maintiennent leur position